-Welcome, everyone.
Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
You're here.
You're watching at home.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for watching.
Let's get to some news.
Well, guys, yesterday,
the director of the CDC
appeared on four
Sunday morning talk shows
to defend the quick reversal
of mask recommendations
for vaccinated Americans.
[ Scattered
cheers and applause ]
Yeah. See,
half of the audience is clapping
because I think a lot of people
don't understand the new rules.
[ Laughter ]
People -- America
hasn't felt this confused
since Dunkin' Donuts started
selling avocado toast.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know what we do.
-Where am I?
-I get it --
it's a confusing time
when Best Buy has tougher
health rules than the CDC.
You know?
[ Laughter ]
That's right --
somehow CDC guidelines
have become more confusing
than a parking sign
in New York City.
It's like...
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Can I stand here?"
"No. You can stand here
on Tuesday."
"Oh."
[ Laughter ]
That's right --
the director said that,
for the new guidelines to work,
the CDC is asking Americans
to be honest
about their vaccination status.
[ Laughter ]
Really?
People can't even tell the truth
on their Tinder profiles.
You're gonna say -- Really?
[ Laughter ]
Come on.
[ Applause ]
It was a picture of me.
-Yeah.
[ Laughs ]
-Meanwhile,
today, even President Biden
tried to add clarity
to the COVID situation.
I don't think he helped anybody
dressed as
The Phantom of the Opera.
I thought that was interesting.
It was like...
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-Now we're doing half-masks.
-Half-masks.
-We're doing half-masks now.
♪ Slowly... ♪
-♪ Of the night ♪
♪♪
-But Biden announced
some good news --
for the first time
since the pandemic began,
cases are down in all 50 states.
So that's...
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
That's great news.
That's right --
COVID numbers are down
and Instagram posts
of people's brunches are way up.
-Aww.
[ Applause ]
-Look at those eggs. Wow.
Like!
Biden also announced plans
to send 20 million
more vaccine doses abroad
by the end of June.
You know that -- Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's good.
[ Applause ]
You now that when the vaccines
come back home, they'll be like,
"It's actually pronounced
'Pfither.'"
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughs ]
-I went to "Barth-- Barthel--"
Okay. Alright.
Alright. Okay. I know.
-How long --
-What's up?
-How long were you there?
-Two "dayth."
[ Laughter ]
Two dayth.
Speaking of Biden, this weekend,
a "New York Times" report
revealed
what the President is like,
according to people
who work closely with him.
They say Biden's obsessed
with details,
asks many questions,
and displays unexpected warmth.
It's all part of their plan
to release
the most boring
tell-all book of all time.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, wow.
He flosses, too. Oh.
[ Laughter ]
The report also says
that Biden's drink of choice
is Orange Gatorade.
-Oh.
-Whoo!
-Is it?
[ Laughter ]
Or is it just water
with Metamucil?
[ Laughter ]
Okay, sure, Gatorade.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Gatorade. Yeah.
Apparently, Biden also doesn't
like to be served leafy greens
'cause he's afraid
of being photographed
with something in his teeth.
The White House kitchen
is like,
"We're now on Year 5
of not serving salad."
[ Laughter ]
Let's change gears here.
Well, people were
talking about this.
Last night, "60 Minutes"
had a piece on
the existence of UFOs.
And this is what a former top
Pentagon official had to say.
-So what you're telling me
is that UFOs are real?
-Bill, I think
we're beyond that already.
-It sounds nutty, wacky.
-I'm not telling you that --
that it doesn't sound wacky.
What I'm telling you --
it's real.
The question is, what is it?
What are its intentions?
What are its capabilities?
-And, of course,
he's talking about his goatee.
[ Laughter ]
"What are its intentions?
Yes, it's wacky.
Yes, it's nutty."
[ Laughter ]
"I think it's kind of edgy,
and I'm also in a swing band."
[ Light laughter ]
I had no idea
the top Pentagon official
was also in charge of all
the elves in the North Pole.
-Wow.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"Hermey doesn't like
to make toys!"
[ Laughter ]
All I know is,
if aliens are real,
it means we're a year away
from seeing this.
-I'm Lesley Stahl.
-I'm Bill Whitaker.
-I'm Anderson Cooper.
-And I am Gorgalack 368.
-Okay. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, today is May 17th,
and you know what that means --
it is Tax Day.
[ Audience groans lightly ]
Yeah.
[ Crowd boos ]
[ Laughter ]
-What was that?
-I don't know.
Yeah, I get it.
The most popular Google
search today was,
"Can I write off my home
if it's also my office?"
and, "Can I write off my bed
if it's also my desk?"
[ Laughter ]
Since it's Tax Day, can we see
what the head of the IRS
looks like?
Yeah, don't worry if you forgot
to file your taxes.
He looks pretty understanding.
[ Laughter ]
Can I see him again?
Can we bring it --
[ Laughter ]
He looks like his son
just told him,
"I need 10 grand
for deejay school."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Some business news --
I saw that Pabst Blue Ribbon
and Entenmann's are teaming up
to release a new paring
of hard coffee and doughnuts.
Take a look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
-What?
-What?!
-And to make it
a truly balanced breakfast,
just throw in half a pack
of Newport Lights.
There you go -- that's --
-Wow, nice.
-Speaking of new products,
I heard that Mountain Dew
is launching
a birthday cake-flavored drink
called
"Mountain Dew Cake Smash."
Take a look at this thing.
Yep.
[ Audience ohhs ]
On the can, the nutrition facts
just say, "Come on."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And finally,
a woman in California says
she accidentally destroyed
a $26 million lottery ticket
in the washing machine.
[ Audience groans ]
When she told lottery officials
that she lost
a $26 million lottery ticket,
the guy behind her in line
was like,
"Yes, I also lost
a $26 million lottery ticket."
Did you guys hear
about Biden's Venmo?
-Yeah.
-Yes.
-Did you know that
you can do that?
You can go on anyone's Venmo --
you see where --
like, what they spent
their money on.
-Yeah, it's crazy.
-I didn't know that --
That seems wrong, doesn't it?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I guess
"The New York Times" reported
that Biden likes to send
his grandkids money on Venmo.
-Aww.
[ Audience awws ]
-Yeah, again,
this is in that boring book
coming out next week.
[ Laughter ]
Well, within about 10 minutes,
I guess reporters from BuzzFeed
were able to find his account.
Yeah.
What?
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
What?
-What?
-Yeah.
-Yeah-ah.
-What?
[ Laughter ]
He's not alone -- a lot of
people in Washington use Venmo.
And you can see exactly
what they're doing.
-Really?
-Yeah, for instance,
let me show you --
Senator John Hoeven
sent Senator Angus King $50
for...
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He's paying back an old debt.
-He's paying back an old debt.
-Yeah.
-By using a modern...
-And then, next up,
Senator Mark Kelly...
-What? Yeah.
-...sent Senator Rand Paul $15
for...
[ Slide whistle plays notes ]
-Oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Imitates slide whistle ]
Next up, Senator James Lankford
sent Senator Ron Wyden $60
for...
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-Here's another one here,
Senator Gary Peters sent
Congressman Don Young $3 for...
[ Laughter ]
Isn't that unbelievable?
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-And then...
Can you imagine that?
-No, it's crazy.
-Ah!
Next up, Senator Joe --
[ Laughter ]
-Charged him $3 for that.
-He charged him $3...
-Yeah.
-...just to see
if he could do it.
-"Hey, you can do it?"
-"Hey, can you unlock..."
-Yeah. You think it was,
"I'll bet you $3
I can unlock
your iPhone with my face"?
-No, he gives it to him,
and he goes --
-No, he goes, "Hey, $3
if you can open this for me."
-Unlocked it.
-Yeah. "I'm wearing a mask."
-Next up, Senator Joe Manchin
sent Senator Bill Cassidy $75
for...
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
Wow, that's a club
they're starting?
-I have no idea.
This is, like, all coming up.
BuzzFeed's finding out
all of this.
-Yeah.
-Up next,
Congressman Thomas Massie sent
Senator Jim Inhofe $100 for...
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
Congressman Brad Sherman
sent Congressman Paul Tonko $100
for...
[ Laughter and applause ]
There you go.
It's worth the money.